This painting by Hans Holbein symbolizes the end of an age when bishop and lord were the sole masters of power and wisdom.
Among the first to sense this change were the Low Countries.
Burgundian possession that Charles V was to acquire in 1519 from Habsburg's Austria.
Before they'd had a chance to topple the Duke of Burgundy, Charles the Bold.
Incited to revolt and then abandoned by King Louis XI, the city of Liège underwent violent pillaging in 1458.
The stronger Swiss cantons were able to bring the haughty duke to his knees at Gandon and again at Moa in 1476.
In 1499, Switzerland obtained her independence.
Its own Christian unity began to founder, weakened by its own contradiction, desire for wealth and worldly power, even more than it was by the Reformation.
In 1517, Luther rose up against the church and its policy of selling indulgences, like tickets to heaven.
Germany rebelled, followed by Sweden, under Gustav Vasa, Finland, Denmark, and Norway.
In Zurich, a man called Zwingli initiated democratic reform.
And by 1540, one Calvin had made of Geneva the Rome of Protestantism.
Calvinism, born in the Swiss Academy, soon spread to all of that country.
And to Germany, Poland, Hungary, England, Scotland, France, and the Low Countries.
And the Council of Trent in Sesson until 1563 thought Protestantism as best could in an already changed world.
In the Low Countries, the beggars of the sea rose up in arms.
There, careful, old man!
Eh, what's that you say?
Look who's here!
Time, here, what's your name?
Eh, what?
What are you doing here?
Why, what's in it to you?
Arrest this man!
uh don't let them get away with this hey all right you guys that's it run run faster run run
better think twice before messing with you and it's uh right you might need this huh a second
hey big fella when you finish with that table could you send it over here gentlemen care for
a beer here you are now my dear girl it's all right it's all right he's just served him a drink
his faraway madrid castle philip the second not have cared less about political or religious
tolerance for the troubled netherlands to quell the beggar's revolt he sent the inquisition duke
of alva's bloody dictatorship special tribunals and the execution of catholic leaders like egmont
and earl next step is to build embankments around these artificial lakes once that's done we'll
reclaim large stretches of land people were fleeing the country by the thousand while the beggars of
of the sea were capturing Labrielle. In 1572, emigrants were setting up a prosperous cloth
industry in England. Yes, yes, that seems all right, but be very careful. The insurrection
became widespread. The war with Spain would continue for 80 years. William of Orange was
named Stadthauder, or Chief Magister, and in France, the St. Bartholomew's Day Massacre
began. Ahead! All right, men, ready now. No matter. We'll just have to explore this sector,
Though the bulk of our troops will have an easy time of it.
That bulk, not hulk, he doesn't mean you.
Go to it, pal.
Watch out, pal, there's one left.
The patrol's been attacked here by rebel forces.
On your guard, man.
Sure won't be from thirst.
Successes, friends.
Oh, I'll teach you a...
Excuse me.
You'll pay for this.
Huh?
Where you hiding, coward?
You little...
City friends must have taken care of them.
Lopez, huh?
He's a little hard of hearing, but he's got a nice side.
Infuriated by Spanish crimes on their soil,
the Catholic Southern provinces united with their Calvinist Northern neighbors.
But when fanatics abused the situation, division set in once again, this time for good.
The Catholic provinces signed the Treaty of Arras.
While at Dutrekt in the north, the United provinces were established.
I am to approve.
And unity will be our strength.
Christ the Lord counsels us to come into the house of the Lord
and to gather in all lands that have gone astray.
And the Lord tells us to call him whene'er we're in need.
To call him, to call him and help with God's hand.
The door will be open to you, even to women, saith the Lord.
Knock, and the door shall open, so saith the Lord.
Call on me.
Yes.
Fine.
Don't forget to knock, knock.
Okay, huck.
Yes.
There you go.
You see, I hear you loud and clear.
What's that church bell ringing for at this hour?
Beats me.
Let's go see.
Those men, I said.
1581, the act of abjuration against tyrants and criminals
proclaimed the downfall of Philip II
and the establishment of the Republic of the United Provinces.
The transition was not a peaceful one, to be sure.
On July 10, 1584, William of Orange, Count of Nassau,
was assassinated at Delft.
There was no doubt who was behind the crime.
Philip II.
The States General was formed under the chairmanship of Holland,
whose name came into use for all of the seven United Provinces as a whole.
Be with you, my friends. Hope you find lots of herring.
Well, bye.
Prosper city of Antwerp, which handled 40% of world trade, was set upon by Spanish troops and sacked.
One-third of her merchants fled to London.
From then on, Antwerp took second place to Amsterdam.
Could you come and help me crush the salt?
Wait a sec. I just figured out a new way of cleaning.
It works real good.
Yeah, but it looks like it's the ocean you're cleaning, not the barrels, eh, friend?
Uh, wait. Too bad. It was heavy.
It's the beast. I'll teach you how dumb these sharks are.
Why don't you come and help?
One sec.
Oh dear, what a load.
Fooling on. I'm fooling around.
Well, thanks, pal. I'm all right.
I'll just pitch them over.
Now you can invent a new way of cleaning, right, old pal?
What a haul we made this time.
1587. In England, Elizabeth had Mary Stewart executed.
Because of Elizabeth's support for the Netherlands,
The Spanish governor, Alexander Farnes, called for her downfall.
For this, Philip II decided to do battle in a big way.
He prepared his invincible armament.
I'm getting a little tired of this.
Fuck.
In that same year, 1587, Francis Drake led an expedition to punish the Spaniards
and destroyed and looted part of the Spanish fleet at Cadiz.
The one who hired this crew?
Yes.
They're all good-for-nothings.
You deserve a good stretch of fatigue due to yourself.
Yes, Bob.
Great idea to have a beer at your place.
Nice of you to come help me.
Hey! Sorry, never on Saturday.
It's Saturday's clean day.
Why am I thirsty?
The beer's downstairs.
Where?
There's a jug in the kitchen.
What's with this beer?
He went and drank my soapy water.
Hey there, pal.
Hey, what's the matter?
Thirsty.
Still?
Nice weather for the season, eh, boss?
Ah, humid, perhaps.
is that those spouts are still blocking the harbor, what's next?
Blockade's gone on long enough, we'll go bankrupt.
I put a stop?
Yep, I joked, yeah.
What I'd do is storm those dreaded Spanish vessels that are blocking our way out of the port,
and believe me, if you put me in command of a war fleet.
Those devils cutting slivers before you can see track, and that's what I'd do.
What's about it, eh?
Yes, but what he says ain't all that bad, don't you agree?
Well, what do you say?
Well, now, let's talk seriously, shall we?
Well, we've got to plan on constructing a common trading freight capable of getting around the blockade without useless battles, and I propose this plan for the approval of all.
So, Spanish ships prevented all foreign merchandise from reaching port.
The East India Company was founded in 1594 in order to deal directly with faraway markets.
Let's talk turkey. I'm a banker, and I'm able to sponsor this outfit.
Although the arrangements are well underway, nothing prevents us from studying your proposal, my good sir.
Let's say I accept this order. Fine, but what's my share of the deal?
A good down payment and add to profits?
Split the profits? Never, forget that idea.
But listen, it's my boat after all, mister.
Ship out there, the darkest one,
it's a warship to protect our ships
if they're attacked by the Span-
You hear that?
No worries for them, eh, pal?
There they go.
And they'll pitch, and they'll roll, and they'll pitch,
and they'll whoop, and whoop!
What are you doing?
I was just playing.
Invincible Armada's defeat considerably weakened the Spanish fleet.
No longer could it effectively block Dutch trade.
Take shape!
See what they brought us?
Yeah.
Step aside.
It's very fragile.
Did you hear?
Yeah, it's very fragile.
It breaks easy.
Like a little help.
God, you dimwits.
Well, at least this one's okay.
Better than none.
Boss, um, your tea, yeah.
You take one or two sugars.
Great East India Company's vessels ranged far and wide,
bartering and trading and reaping enormous profits.
In short, the company was an unprecedented success.
I told you so.
I'm sure I'm not.
1602.
The Great East India Company was officially chartered.
1603.
By the beginning of the century, the company had become a power to be reckoned with.
Elizabeth of England was no more.
Shakespeare staged Hamlet, and then Othello and Macbeth.
Samuel Champlain headed for Canada.
Well then, it's your newest invention.
Most certainly, Buret.
It's a mill.
A mill for grinding coffee.
Nice find, eh?
Especially when it stops.
Good gosh.
You're breaking my...
You are a fussy one.
My friends, this child is an artist.
Aha!
He has a gift for drawing.
My lord, sir.
Excuse my lateness, I had a job to finish.
Huh?
A painting alone won't feed a man.
Not all clients are as generous as you are.
You'll get your pay if my portrait's a good one, if it looks like me.
Certainly.
Lessons.
Hmm.
Something wrong?
Portraits are fine, all of them.
A little break.
Let's see how it's going.
Aha!
A genius!
Hmm?
All my compliments looks just like me, very nice.
And now, let's have a look over at your youngsters.
Ah, I'm sure this little gentleman has captured all of my nobility.
What in the name of...
Throw out this impertinent brat.
Leave out.
I'm fine, don't get all upset everybody, I'm good.
Unbelievable, I'm miserable.
Call that.
Don't be one of it, one day this time will be the rage of Europe, you'll see.
How a man named Hans Lieberche perfected the telescope.
Or at least, that's how the story goes.
The Maritime Academy.
Of this uplifting career.
And you will see later on, when you sail away under the proud banner of our fair land,
are you daydreaming again?
Uh-uh-uh, sir.
Silence, poorest of students.
Follow the example set by your neighbor.
See how attentive he is, how studious.
Now then, we'll move on to our exercise, eh?
Yes, not today. Very good.
Now, what do you call that?
i suggest we get on with the practice a fine idea my boy now we shall do an exercise you sir who
will be punished your class is in chaos at your orders and your officers now what is the meaning
of all this laughing in spite of the war life goes on as usual ah another rowing contest in 1609 a
12-year truce was signed with spain that same year the bank of amsterdam was established it
would become the most powerful bank in the world in canada champlain founded quebec city
Say, that reminds me of something.
Don't be angry.
In 1614, the Dutch set up an outpost on a faraway island they would later call New Amsterdam.
Fifty years later, it was conquered by the English and renamed New York.
But let's not get ahead of ourselves.
There, 1618, Rubens painted his Daughters of Lucie.
The defenestration of Prague unleashed the Thirty Years' War.
Golden Age of the United Provinces.
Franz Hals, Peter de Hooke, Vermeer, and many others.
In 1532, a 26-year-old painter attended his first anatomy lesson.
His name, Rembrandt, Roycedale, and his mill.
Medicine and science also progressed, but not without their troubles.
Harvey discovered the circulation of the blood.
Scholars in Paris called his find paradoxical, useless, false, impossible, absurd, and harmful to mankind.
Our son will be a great painter. You'll see.
All the time, Papa.
There was Kepler, the brilliant mathematician, who was persecuted for his free thinking.
His 74-year-old mother was imprisoned for sorcery.
There was Galileo, who had to negate his theories, or be declared a heretic.
But Holland at the time was a land of tolerance.
Hugo Gracia's father of human rights was born there, as well as Descartes,
who dared to question Aristotle.
And Spinoza, a refugee from the Spanish Inquisition, who chose the Netherlands as his new home.
Today's superb. I shall plant nice rows of tulips.
And there's a nice bulb.
2,000 florins.
Once, going, twice, going, going, and it's sold.
Good work, my good sir.
A good buy at 2,000 florins.
And now let me show you a tulip of great worth, the Semper Augustus.
Yes, 1,500.
1,800.
2,000.
2,000 florins.
3,000.
Oh, my good sir, it's yours for 3,000 florins.
And for our next item.
Don't fooling around, I'm buying.
But I intend to buy.
How dare you presume.
Come, gentlemen, gentlemen.
Allow me to present the marvel of our time, the black tulip.
Feast your eyes.
Close look.
Whatever the price.
Let me make an offer, too.
Well, then, here's mine.
Just add a bit to that.
That's all I've got.
Chief, what about your sheep?
To that, I add my sheep.
Not enough, sir.
Mine.
You have nothing else?
This, too.
get all worked up to this man it's true in 1634 in antwerp the viceroy tulip was sold for four
bulls eight pigs twelve sheep a bed and quite a few other items this is the best deal you've ever
made chief thanks to me for one the best deal i've ever made chief don't do that tulips in 1620 the
puritans left for england from there they would soon board the mayflower 78 men and 24 women and
set out to found the American nation.
As for Holland, she was entering her golden age.